notre coup de coeur aussi dès cette
semaine évidemment on peut pas y
échapper
c'est un antoine pardon star war stories
qui sont aujourd'hui dans nos salles
donc c'est un spin off un spin off c'est
à dire que c'est un un dérivé de
l'histoire initiale qui situe entre
l'épisode 3 et l'épisode 4 les
connaisseurs apprécieront et me suivront
et qui raconte comment les rebelles ont
volé les plans de l'étoile noire
nous pensons qu'il peut nous aider
quand as tu vu ton père pour la dernière
fois c'est quoi ces questions
alors c'est très réussi pour un spin off
on pouvait avoir des craintes en disant
ça va pas être purement commerciales etc
c'est très réussi c'est très sombre on
retrouve des personnages les épisodes
précédents des épisodes suivants
il ya des surprises on va en parler on a
laissé les spectateurs de découvrir
voilà mais c'est dans nos salles à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est dur 2h14
l'union sauf notre rêve
et puis un petit coucou aussi au film
d'emmanuelle bercot s'apaisent de la
fille de bresc qui est encore de naussac
il faut absolument voir josé manuel
bercot c'est à la fois une grande
actrice et une grande réalisatrice je
pensais me roy de maïwenn où elle joue
les formidables et elle réalise aussi
très bien et ça raconte l'histoire du
scandale du médiator donc c'est aussi à
voir dans les salles sectionnement ya
pas de vraie compassion pour tous les
vrais résistants au père je suis quoi